jennifer lopez says she and ben affleck
are in it for the long haul
this is a thrill i can't stop smiling
the 52-year-old triple threat covers the
latest issue of rolling stone magazine
and inside she's opening up about how
their dynamic has changed since
rekindling their romance 18 years after
calling off their engagement we were
about to get married it didn't work out
and it was just a bad heartbreak it was
like
a tough one for me quote we've both
grown we're the same and we're different
and that's what's nice
and while jen says she won't talk about
her relationship too much she does add
quote having a second chance at real
love we learned a lot we know what's
real what's not real so it's just the
game has changed i do love that i love
it jen also reflects on their past
relationship saying it was one of the
happiest times in her life but all that
public hate really got to them quote it
really destroyed our relationship from
the inside out because we were just too
young to understand at that time what
were really the most important things in
life it was my first kind of heartbreak
i mean i had like a puppy love
heartbreak when i was like 12.
you know what i mean but i don't really
count that one it was my first like
adult heartbreak was it because it was
so public and we wanted to know every
single
thing about your relationship well that
didn't help the marry me star says we
shouldn't expect a breakup this time
around
quote i don't think we would have gotten
back together if we thought that was
where it was headed we feel like what we
found again is so much more important
and how we protect that and how we live
our lives what to share what not to
share is the balance that we have now
the benefit of experience and the wisdom
that we gained over the years
we're having such a good time
and jen she isn't the only one keeping
their love tight to the vest back in
october the last dual star played coy
with e.t when asked about their
relationship i don't know if you are
aware of how good the internet thinks
you look it's like all everyone's
talking about lately i think you might
be no i'm not
i'm really not ben um i is it the jlo
glow like how much happiness is she
bringing into your life because you're
looking good man is it the corduroy is
that when she was big on the quarter
because i wasn't sure about court they
told me it's fall
a month later jen was by ben's side to
support him at the premiere of his flick
the tender bar where ben opened up to
e.t about the intensity of life in the
spotlight
in my life um
i've been through a lot of different
kinds of experiences with the press and
it's just a it's like a function of what
you do right it's not my favorite part
of the job it's not what i would choose
to do but it is a responsibility in mind
i take seriously and
you have to promote this work and things
seem to be better than ever for the
lovebirds in fact a source recently told
e.t jen helps bring out the best in the
49 year old oscar winner quote he loves
jennifer and says she makes him a better
person and motivates him to work hard he
wants to take care of her even though
she doesn't need him to that is just the
type of guy he is
[Music]